[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now no matter
what your weight loss goals are
dr nash can help take a look at
dominic's incredible results
working with dr nash i lost 70 pounds in
three and a half months and reversed my
type 2 diabetes and i feel great
look at dominic he lost 98 pounds which
is incredible
but also dr nash welcome to the show you
reversed
type 2 diabetes for dominic how did you
do it
yeah we actually reversed a five-year
diabetic problem in three and a half
months so the problem with type 2
diabetes is usually if you go the
traditional medical route they're going
to focus on controlling the issue
instead of reversing it
when you find out what's really going on
underneath the surface that's causing
the diabetes and focus on that
not only are you going to lose weight
and it's probably going to be
accelerated but just like dominic you're
going to be able to reverse it and
reverse it
fast is that the key because you hear
people talking about diabetes type 2
diabetes and managing symptoms
i mean you changed it you changed this
man's life
right the problem is medical community
community tends to focus on blood sugar
and a1c
and what we really have to focus on is
getting the body sensitive to the
insulin hormone instead that's the
primary driver of type 2 diabetes
and that's one of the things that we do
with people who are diabetic to get the
condition to reverse
all right let's break down the five
metabolic factors that you always talk
about run them down for us today
right so this is what i learned back in
2009 that are like the secret drivers or
sabotagers of weight loss the first one
is going to be toxicity and when we talk
about toxicity we're mainly talking
about things like fatty liver disease
or overgrowth in the gut the second one
is over fed but undernourished meaning
you're getting enough calories and
energy every day but not enough
nutrition to actually correct the damage
the third one is retraining your set
point so that's a part of your brain
that
programs your body to stay at the same
weight usually too high when you have a
weight problem
the la the fourth one a that's acidity
also known as
inflammation inflammation especially
when it hits your organs causes stubborn
belly fat
and then in the case of type 2 diabetes
hormones there can be up to
12 low or imbalanced hormones that if
they are not in the proper position
you can't burn body fat even when you're
eating less and moving more and that's
going to stop the correction of diabetes
cold
dominic and some of your other clients
are these results typical
yeah they're absolutely typical again if
they follow the instructions that we
give them so we have to set up specific
strategies to fix these problems
we also test the body and make sure that
it's going to hold the weight loss
having you eat between 2 000 and 3 000
calories a day
because we want to make sure the pro the
weight loss is permanent for you
but it does come down to making sure
that you do whatever it is
that we create for you and every week
you bring a special what do you have for
us this week
if you were to call me do the evaluation
normally it's 97
but if you mention that you saw me on
las vegas now then i'm going to give you
a spot for only 9.97 that's
90 off its normal price but you have to
go through the website to get it if you
call the office you're not going to be
able to get it at that low number
so make sure you check out the website
that's on the screen i've only got 10
spots though jc i can only do it for 10.
all right that'll do it for us today
have a great day las vegas now we're
back tomorrow